now for British men who were arrested in
Cambodia over what police they're called
pornographic dance have now been
released but one David Jones remains
under arrest and is now facing trial
there are amongst a group of ten people
arrested during a party at the villa in
Siem Reap well Tom Jeffries is one of
those who was arrested but it's now been
released he joins us now from Portsmouth
and Tom really appreciate you talking to
us this morning
welcome home just him tell us what you
were doing in Cambodia in the first
place I mean I've been living in
Cambodia for about three years just
working at various different hostels and
bars and sort of doing the same same
sort of thing that happens when we were
getting arrested for the last three
years what happened on the day of the
arrest I mean I had arrived at the party
about 45 minutes before the police did
when I decided not to go to the cinema
or instead what I saw was just people
drinking and dancing and in fact it was
raining quite heavily about maybe ten
minutes before the police arrived and we
were all dis cowering underneath the
underneat sort of a balcony from the
right police say they released images of
the party of tourists we've been told
that those photos were taken three or
four years ago so that wasn't the group
that year with who were in these photos
but what do you think it is that got the
authorities backs up for them to make
these arrests I'm not really sure I
think they're they're probably just
trying to sort of change they would
change the tourism I guess I'm not too
sure I mean the photo as you say that
they've been circulating is from over
four years ago a bar that I've never
even been to I've never even seen it and
I wasn't even in the country and I was
one of the longest longest running
people at the ten of us in the country
what do you what was going on at this
party that you're at I mean you say it
was just people drinking was anything
else going on for for this ray to take
place it was literally just a swimming
pool there was a barbecue there were
just people drinking beers you know
there was nothing nothing at all that I
would have thought would have caused the
the police to come and right you're in
Cambodia
two years before you arrived in the
country how aware where you of the
country's local culture and customs I
mean I knew very little about the
culture before I got there but whilst I
was there I spent a lot of times with
with Cambodian people when it was never
made apparent that anything like this
would would be offensive to anyone yeah
tell us a little bit more about what it
was like when you arrested because you
were you and along with the other nine
were detained in a rather notorious
prison you had to shave your head for
example what was the experience like
yeah I mean it was horrendous it was
scary I mean to begin with we didn't
know how how far it was gonna go the
actual prison we were in a cell about
five meters by four meters with 25 other
25 other prisoners you know it's it was
terrifying it was terrifying the Foreign
Office on their website say those who
are arrested then convicted of a crime
face rather lengthy sentences you must
count yourself very lucky what was that
like known that you were imprisoned
accused of this crime and you could have
been facing a rather long prison
sentence I think the worst thing was
just trying to prepare yourself because
it could have been as you say it could
have been up to a year and it was it was
horrendous but we considered that the
best thing to do was just prepare
ourselves for the worst I think the most
important thing to remember though is
that there is still someone out there
Danny's a very good friend of mine and
he is still unfortunately going through
everything at this time why is he still
there and the rest of you were allowed
to leave I think that's probably a
question best the for the lawyer I've
been in contact with anyone since I left
the country on reflection is there
anything that you would have done
differently no I don't think so because
I honestly don't feel like we did
anything wrong in the first place you
know I might gone to the cinema instead
of to the to the bar
if I could have gone back and made that
decision again but no as far as I was
aware I wasn't offending anyone and as I
said I have many Cambodian friends out
there and none of them ever made it
clear that what I was doing been
offensive yeah because I mean I only
asked because the the villa the villa
was near the angkor wat's
temple a Buddhist temple considered
sacred to many of the locals there
I guess the allegation that have been
leveled at you was that you were
disrespecting the local laws and customs
I can see that it was relatively close
to the temples but it was exactly that
it was relatively close I was probably
closer to a street called pub Street
which is dead center in the centre of
Siem Reap so I again had no reason to
think that drinking would be offensive
yeah at what point were you told that
you were gonna be able to return home I
was told literally just out just after I
got a present maybe the next day and
then and then where did you write home
after that when were you able to leave
oh I got on a flight straightaway the
next day and what was it like being
coming back home it's weird being back
in the UK it's quite nerve-wracking I
don't know how this is going to affect
me being able to get a job it's
obviously been three years a surprising
amount has has changed here and I mean
I've changed a lot compared to the
competitive country I left at all yeah
would you go back to Cambodia again I
would love to go back to Cambodia again
like I have absolutely no bad feelings
about the country I've so many people
that I miss out there and I would love
to see them all again um now that you're
back home do you get the sense that the
authorities in Cambodia use you as an
example
they wanted to send a message to British
backpackers foreign backpackers who were
travelling in the country who were
working in the country I'm not sure if
we were used as an example as such I
think that they want to do something
different with their country - what what
was happening at the time and
this is the way they did it okay Tom
Jefferies thanks for your time thank you
very much Cheers